i am happy to announce that we
have today signed funding
of 60 million euros through the
joint eu folio program in favor
of youth and specifically
disadvantaged youth through
economic, social and political cohesion
we have  also confirm
today our desire to pursue
the population in areas as
varied as transport
environment energy research innovation and
civil protection
tunisia is for us a
valuable example especially in the region
in terms of consolidation  democratic
the european union remains committed to
supporting structural reforms in
the economic and social field
we believe that la liga could
help tunisia to diversify its economy to
increase its competitiveness and to
develop its exports to the european union
its largest trading partner
tunisia and the european union
also share the same objective of strengthening  cer
stability security and peace in the
region
we have, as the
representative said, signed an
extremely important agreement bear on the
genesis the employability of young people
of integration at the level of the labor circuit
it shakes up economic but also  to
improve their participation in public life
and political life in general,
we of course raised the question
of the league, a project which is important for
our European friends but also as
important, if not more important, for
Tunisia,
we have underlined the importance of
reaching  to an immediate ceasefire of
hostilities happening today in
tripoli